coveted numbers are increasing again in
many parts of this country raising fears
of another difficult winter at least 35
states have seen daily covet cases trend
upward over the past two weeks that's
according to johns hopkins university
mola lenghi is in one of those states
we're talking about colorado now mola
good morning to you how are officials
responding there
well good morning gail yeah the governor
here has signed an executive order
declaring colorado a high-risk covid
state that order makes all adults here
all of them eligible for the covid
vaccine booster of course this is an
attempt to try to disrupt what's
becoming an alarming trend one that's
beginning to overwhelm hospitals
we still want to provide the very best
care to our patients but that's just a
little more difficult
in these trying times this is icu nurse
tracy pre helping in the seemingly
endless fight against colorado's spike
in covid19 cases i don't know how anyone
could not have feelings of burnout based
on what we've endured these last two
years what you're going through right
now as a staff is it sustainable right
now it is not sustainable we need
changes there are only so many resources
95 percent of the state's icu beds are
now full and the department of health
says nearly 40 percent of hospitals in
the state are expected to experience
staffing shortages within a week that's
why colorado's governor has called for
500 additional beds and activated the
state's crisis standards of care giving
hospitals flexibility in allocating
resources including affecting the ratio
of staff to patients i think everybody
is still obviously committed to doing
the best they can and take care of
patients but i think there's also sort
of a sense of
wanting the community to step up to dr
michelle barron senior medical director
of infection prevention at uc health
stepping up means getting vaccinated
about 80 percent of the state's more
than 1400 hospitalized covid patients
are unvaccinated there's been a high
percentage of individuals vaccinated
above the national average but that
means that 30 percent of people are
still not vaccinated which in the
setting of the delta variant means
they're vulnerable in this context 30
percent is still a lot absolutely and i
think other places in the united states
are starting to see sort of similar
trends where i think we had this magical
number in our heads that oh once we
reach x amount of vaccination we're good
and clearly that's not the case
nearly 80 percent of eligible people
here in the state of colorado have
received at least one dose of vaccine we
should point out that's higher than the
national average but there are three
counties in this state that remain under
40 percent in terms of their vaccination
rates and folks here at uc health say
it's those unvaccinated people that are
driving this spike not just here in
colorado but nationwide tony
mola thank you very much